police have revealed the names of six of
the seven people killed in Highland Park
they include the parents of a little boy
who was pulled to safety by strangers
this morning those seven stolen lives
are being mourned by their families and
a stunned Community Adriana Diaz is
outside North Shore Highland Park
Hospital which is treating some of the
survivors Adriana is just heartbreaking
good morning
good morning Nikki it really is those
patients being treated they range in age
from 14 years old to someone in their
70s and an eight-year-old boy had to be
airlifted to a Chicago Children's
Hospital we've been talking to survivors
and they are shaken to the core not only
by what they experienced but the fact
that these shootings are more common and
almost feel inevitable
it was the worst moment of my entire
life
Natalie Laurent says there was no
mistaking the pops for fireworks on the
4th of July so loud like a war movie you
know not like one shot like rapid fire
she and her family had just sat down on
the curb to enjoy the parade when
bullets rained down on the crowd we just
got up and started running I grabbed my
youngest son and my husband had my other
two kids my mom was running with us she
wiped out and fell and got separated
from us when I was down on the ground
the guy next to me
looked like his leg was shot off and the
woman in front of him was completely
covered with blood in the chaos Lorenz
still tried to Shield her small children
from the reality I was like spelling out
shooting because I didn't want my kids
to hear I told them it was fireworks
that someone had set off fireworks and
they got out of control and you spelled
the word shooting out so your kids
wouldn't understand yeah I was like
there was an
s-h-o-o-t-i-n-g seven people all left
home to celebrate our nation and never
came back among the victims Catherine
Goldstein Nicholas Toledo who was
visiting from Mexico Jacqueline Sondheim
a teacher at a local synagogue Irina and
Kevin McCarthy and Stefan Strauss
Lawrence remember seeing the McCarthy's
and their two-year-old son next to them
that's their plaid blanket it makes no
sense
how anyone could do this to a child
where there are children
to think of the that little boy
and to think that that could have just
as easily been us
how far away were you from them I mean
my kids were sitting on their blanket we
kept being like guys that's not your
blanket I mean inches
away from us
how did we survive like why did we
survive
according to our Chicago station WBBM
that little boy the McCarthy son was
found by bystanders at the parade this
community rallied around him word spread
on social media looking for his family
he was eventually reunited with his
grandparents his parents are gone a
GoFundMe account has been started for
him and this little boy just two years
old now faces a long road ahead without
his parents Vlad
Adriana you know when I saw the little
photo of him covered in blood his socks
covered in blood uh I I just bought
tears to my eyes and now that child has
become effectively the symbol of this
plague in the United States of America
it's heartbreaking Adriana thank you
very much for your reporting